-The Weirdos. Thank you guys
so much for being here.
Chris, we know each other --
-Yes. I love you.
-I love you, too --
for a long time.
[ Laughter ]
But can The Weirdos quickly
introduce themselves?
-[ English accent ]
Yeah, right, I'm Donk
and, believe it or not,
I'm the normal one.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Except, I play drums.
-Ah, the drummer, Dunk, yes.
-My name is The Wizard,
but I'm not --
I'm not that kind of wizard.
I'm -- I'm the kind of guy
who just is super smart
and -- and I do magic.
-Like a normal --
like a wizard.
-That is what a wizard --
-Yeah, yeah,
-That's a wizard, mate.
-Like a normal wizard.
Yeah.
-Okay, okay, yes.
-And you, right here,
very beautiful.
-My name is Angel Moon.
I'm a singer.
I'm 109 light-years old.
-Wow!
-How old are you, Jimmy?
You're gorgeous.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's really kind of creepy.
-I like that, no. Oh, my gosh.
Thank you very much.
I'm much, much older than that.
[ Laughter ]
How about back there?
-♪ Sparkman ♪
♪ I play guitar ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Sparkman.
You play guitar, but it's weird.
Do you sing as well,
in the band?
-♪ No, I don't like to sing ♪
[ Laughter ]
-No, he plays the guitar.
-Yeah, but you have
a beautiful voice.
Maybe you should try singing.
-♪ Mm ♪
♪ Not for me ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ I'm too shy ♪
-♪ You're too shy, of course ♪
-He's very shy.
-But your manager
is here tonight as well.
Can we get a shot
of your manager?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Bruce, Bruce Cakemix is here.
-Whoa, whoa, no, Jimmy --
-Well, thank you for being here.
Jimmy, no.
-No, not Cakemix.
"Kehkehmix."
He gets very angry
if you call him Mr. Cakemix.
-I'm sorry. Bruce Kehkehmix?
-Spelled like Cakemix,
but it's pronounced Kehkehmix.
[ Laughter ]
-Don't make him angry.
You won't like him
when he's angry.
-Yeah, you won't like it.
-That man in a sweater vest
will get angry?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
This is the first time
we've had a band on
from another planet.
Donk, what planet are you from?
-Well, it's really hard
to pronounce,
so we just call it Melissa.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
And, on Melissa,
do you get
"The Tonight Show" there?
-Well, yeah, but,
you see,
you've broadcast it a while
and it takes a long time
for transmissions
to reach our planet.
-Is there a time delay
where they're from?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, back on our planet,
you're still riding
around in a yellow cab
with Queen Latifah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah!
That was a good jam.
I remember that one.
Angel Moon, what's your favorite
thing about Earth, so far?
-My favorite thing
about Earth is
probably you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪ Is you, Jimmy ♪
-I'm just in --
I'm in love.
-Wait, wait.
-♪ All I think about is you ♪
♪ Jimmy ♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪ It's all that I can do ♪
♪ Every day ♪
♪ When I'm dreaming away ♪
♪ About you ♪
♪ Jimmy, Jimmy ♪
♪ J ♪
♪ For Jimmy ♪
-J for Jimmy.
-Wow, my God!
Angel Moon, that was the most
beautiful...
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah!
-...beautiful
voice I've ever heard.
It's really, Chris,
she has an amazing voice.
-She has an amazing voice.
-She does.
-She really --
-[ Laughs ]
-She really -- You really do.
-Chris, you're a big fan
of The Weirdos
and you've been wanting to work
with them for a while.
-Yeah.
-How did you finally meet?
-Well, the rest of the band,
Coldplay, and I,
we went to --
we were lucky enough
to get tickets
to see them in concert
and we just tried to get
their attention, to say,
"Please, one day,
could we work together?"
[ Laughter ]
And...
-Yeah.
-We have a clip, actually,
of the moment that we met.
-Of Coldplay
at a Weirdos concert?
-Yeah, because we love to go see
things together and --
-As a band, yeah.
You and Coldplay,
you and the band just travel.
You do everything together.
-Everything.
[ Laughter ]
And we'd just finished at a nail
spa together and we went
[ Laughter ]
to see.
-You were getting mani-pedis
and then you went
to the Weirdos concert.
-Exactly.
-And we have a video.
Check this out.
-This is how we met.
-♪ So biutyful ♪
♪♪
♪ Yes, you're biutyful ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Wow. That's amazing.
-Yeah.
-I see it now, yeah.
Now, Angel Moon,
gosh, you are very beautiful,
so it goes with the song,
but tell us about the new song.
-Ooh!
Jimmy, the song "Biutyful"
is spelled differently
where we come from,
but, really, the song is
about how
there is beauty and magic
in all things and all people.
-Yeah, I agree.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Is that what it meant?
-That's it. [ Laughs ]
-That's what it's about.
-Weirdos, I wanted to thank you,
again, for being here
and you're going to perform
for us tonight.
I really appreciate this.
And a big New York City welcome.
-Thank you, Jimmy.
We love you so much.
This is the best day
♪ Of my life ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Oh, my.
I love you guys.
The Weirdos,
featuring Chris Martin
of Coldplay, everybody.
Catch them on the
Music of the Spheres World Tour
and they're performing for us
later on the show.